[Music]
how sweet is to be loved fine thank you
man Merry Christmas
how sweet is to be loved by you eat if
it's shelter so what's up
[Music]
please don't wanna send my ups and downs
[Music]
where´s we love and devotion deeply
touching my emotion I wanna stop thank
you baby I just wanna stop but thank you
baby
it's that sweet egg everybody so much
[Music]
[Music]
thank you thank you how sweet is to be
loved by you
whoa what is happening right now
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank everybody so much closed eyes at
night wondering where would happy
without you in my life everything I did
was just need for if we wrap in scenes
up in there before you bad enough to we
all cried a love so sweet so many ways I
won't stop
thank you baby I just wanna stop
Wow thank you baby it's a day out Street
you see while Oh turn around and ah ah
how sweet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Wow I guess I don't know huh whoa okay
yeah I just recently had my daughter
she's like three months old and I'm like
so you know I'm like just doing my thing
is the first time dad and honestly like
thank you I don't know I'm at a loss for
words I've never had an experience like
this I feel truly blessed when I came
into the station today I was expecting
to play a few tunes make some people
happy make some people smile I feel like
years of working on the subway and
making people smile it's really just
paying off in its own way
I feel so fortunate sweet
[Music]
if you want to see another heartwarming
flashmob check out the video right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there